Imagine the head of your company comes into your office really
excited about this new report her friend showed her from a different organization.
This other CEO has been bragging about how he can track inventory, sales,
and profitability on his phone,
and how he has all this key information now in the palm of his hand.
Now that the big boss at your company knows this is possible, she wants one too.
Really who can blame her?
Being able to visually analyze your data in one place is the dream.
A good visualization is a powerful way to facilitate
smart decision-making and identify potential issues early on.
There's just one teensy tiny problem.
The reality is your company's data is all over the place.
As a budding business intelligence professional,
you know that your company,
like most companies, has relatively low data analytics maturity.
The data has to be pulled from a whole bunch of different locations and sources with
formats ranging from Hadoop to SQL to Excel, even PDF files.
Some companies solve this problem by using
a centralized data warehouse to merge data from different teams.
But if you're working at a smaller company,
it may not be an option to have some fancy centralized data warehouse where
all this key information is reliably stored and consistently structured.
To be able to create a report like the owner has in mind,
you're going to need to take data from each department,
like marketing with their Facebook and Salesforce data,
finance with their many Excel spreadsheets.
IT with their SQL database and research and development,
who for some reason are storing things in PDFs,
and funnel all of this data together for the report.
Somehow, you're going to need to mash up
all these different data sources, funnel them together,
and somehow do some cleanup where the data quality leaves something to be desired,
and finally, create a report.
How on earth are you going to tame this mess of data sources and
get them all working in harmony to meet your boss's needs?
That, my friends, is where preparing and modeling data comes to the rescue.
From my perspective, it's where the Power BI software is at its best.
With Power BI, we'll see that we can handle a huge variety of data sources.
Then it provides us with an inexpensive yet effective option so
that we don't need to spend money on
a costly solution like a sophisticated data warehouse,
let alone the time.
Power BI is a powerful tool that will allow you to effectively
prepare and model your data regardless of your company's size.